let's play nymca never played before
the first sub challenge we'll have a
chill 10 minute rapid game
we'll try and be instructive here i'll
play e4
opponent rated oh we have played before
we played three times before
so opponent rated just over two thousand
wasn't the world supposed to end in 2012
there was that one movie
oh okay panziani time so d5 is one of
the
the best most challenging moves against
ponziani
and the move to play here is queen a4
the benefit to d5 is if i were to take
queen takes i don't have knight c3
but after queen a4 things get tricky
it's a tricky position if black hasn't
seen this before it's not easy to figure
out what to do if you don't know the
main line
because i'm pinning the knight there's
still pressure against both pawns
bishop d7 breaks the pin but obstructs
the queen from defending d5
um now this is playable this is a gambit
but i am
um going up a pawn
thank you midnight js yeah it's after
midnight for me it's 12 53
am the week is just beginning it's
monday for me
and probably for most other people too
um yeah so knight d4 attacked my queen
move all the way back to support the
knights
actually i went through a phase of
playing this as black against ponziani
there are some interesting ideas but um
white is supposed to be
a bit better here at least according to
the engine
remember looking this up with stockfish
a few years ago
and john welcome back john gifting to cl
smith
shout out to cl smith and shout out to
john
do we have a john command i think we do
oh the giant command links to john
bartholomew wait what
well shout out to 95 horatio
there we go okay so yeah this is a move
hitting my queen
if i play queen g3 it can get weird
because bishop d6 i win the pawn i
run into rook g8 i don't think i want to
deal with that
so queen e2 might be the more
solid approach pinning
the e pawn preparing to play d3
yeah d3 looks attractive now
because on one hand this pawn it can be
a strength controlling space
but in this case it looks more of a
weakness
oh there are still some interesting
lines i think i'll go ahead and take
um because black could take back
castling actually defended the pawn with
tactics because if takes
i can't take back his rookie eight
and black's probably choosing between
takes first
or rookie eight first both moves are
interesting
when do i sleep i sleep when i'm
not awake okay bishop e3
looks reasonable i'm actually not sure
if i want to castle
kingside or queenside
there's some debate where the king is
safest
and black is actually probably more
prepared to attack on the king's side
so i might stay flexible knight d2 looks
natural
only real developing square for the
knight
and the main goal is just to be solid
like i'm up upon i don't need to go
crazy
i just wanna complete development
simplify not get mated or
brutally attacked
how do you do arrows arrows it's just a
matter of right clicking and dragging
you can't do them on mobile you need a
mouse
and if you have a keyboard then you can
hold down shift
and make them different colors
combination of shift and alt
apologies to those who are colorblind
have i ever been to any african country
yeah i went to senegal back in 2019
um that's the only african country i've
been to chen's immense
i still don't know what that means what
does that mean
welcome back daniel newman chess
who donated there were a few chenza
men's donations
in a recent stream yeah i think i won
the castle
queen side here
actually i'm not sure
i mean this also looks fine this is
actually hard
i guess castling there's queen here
if i castle queenside it gets a bit
sharper
but then i can launch an attack of my
own
let's castle queen side
very possible black will start storming
in
uh in various ways with the pawns
another move to consider is queen d4
just going for a queen trade
the trading queens would simplify a lot
of a lot of things
alexa what does chen's amends mean
winnie okola known professionally as
kenza is a canadian singer
record producer and music video director
from vancouver no that's not what they
said
alexa quiet
it was telling me who kenza is
also f4
also okay first question is what is
black trying to do
does this move it just stares at my very
solid
mini pawn chain um the queen
queen wants to like swing over but i
can't because i'm controlling all these
squares
so f4 would just kick the bishop back
and
gives me some initiative
i might first look to optimize my my
rook
could also go for the trades
f4 is a bit committal though because
then i can't move
like i can't move backwards to f3 and
there's cases where i want the pawn on
f3
to just restrict the light squared
bishop
so
yeah i'm thinking rook here which is
more more flexible
i'm not scared of this
even though maybe that's what bobby
fischer would do
and bishop g4 then i play f3 i think the
plan is to play f4
bishop d6 and then oh bishop d4 there's
queen f4
i guess i just eventually want to trade
the rooks on the e-file
maybe some idea bishop g5 f4
there is a small trap if rook ada i play
bishop g5 and skewer
maybe one one slow plan
is to play h3 just controlling this
preparing g4 and then get the pawns
rolling like f4 g4
because f4 comes with tempo oh b5
okay now question where do where does my
bishop move
this is natural but then it could get
hit again
so i'm thinking this is probably
a bit better
bishop d3 i guess then queen a6
i think b1 b4 c4
actually b4 the queen would hang so
bishop d3 of b4 immediately
and maybe i just take it i'll do this
oh and rmt cheering 200 saying
are you feeling in a ponziani mood
tonight
uh yeah i guess a ponziani
describes my mood describes the opening
in this game
for those just joining this is uh an
interesting line in ponziani
one upon early i'm trying to hold on to
it
i want to start the stream with a clean
game
okay so now there's some tension between
the bishops
um i mean trading
move like trading and then queen d3
i'm not employing my usual like a crazy
aggressive gambit style
because my opponent's basically the one
who gave it to the pawn
so i'm just trying to be controlled be
solid
oh no my pawn i should know if black
takes i play g3
um essentially trapping the bishop and
then rook h1 would win the bishop
now one principle i've mentioned this
before on previous streams
but when you have an end game of bishops
of the same color regardless of rooks
if rooks are on the board or not um
both players in this case should put
their pawns on light squares
oh unless the bishops got traded which i
probably don't mind
i was thinking this but that just loses
our rooks my bishop would be pinned
so maybe g3
or maybe king d2 king d2 actually looks
better
yeah bishops are traded then the color
of the squares that the pawns are on are
less relevant
and what's more relevant is king safety
or king
king activity king safety less relevant
when there's just a rook ending
casual or rated i don't mind usually
when i do viewer challenges
uh viewers can decide if they want to
want the game to be rated
whoa it's minlae what's up minlae gm
menley
you're just in time for a king pawn
ending
shout out to minlae i think we have a
min command
so we just traded everything
except the kings and the pawns um
and because i'm up a pawn this is i
don't even really need to calculate this
is a
a pretty routine win um especially
because my king is more active
i have one nice kind of or two nice
healthy pawn islands
and now we'll see how to how to win in
the end game
when you're up just a single pawn
and the goal goal really is to create a
pass pawn
on the side in which i have the majority
so i have four
on three um so the plan is just to start
advancing
the c4c5
yeah how many people would feel
confident winning this
as white against a strong player
so i feel like this this sort of end
game it's a good exercise
like if you're
if you're a decent end game player you
should be able to like beat a
grand master from this position as white
but could depend on time and nerves and
etc
okay so now i have a few options um i'm
gonna start with c5
kick the king away and then then i can
decide between either playing d6
or taking both moves should be winning
um i think what i'll do is take even
though d6 looks
really just crushing um
then like it's hard for my king to get
in
um i wouldn't want to have a situation
where like my king can't enter and then
i can't make progress but when i take
then already envisioning some zug's van
where whenever the king moves back
i'll be able to move forward and then
start making progress
so black's gonna try and make waiting
moves with the pawns
eventually the pawn moves will run out
actually if f6 i have king e5 so i don't
even need to
um to make more pawn moves
because one last note if a5 just a3 is
simple
um i'll play g3 there's actually
there is a kind of interesting way of
winning this position
which uh opponent might resign so we
might not see it
but i could have just gone in and taken
the pawn and won
like eventually with queening on the
king's side
but i do want to illustrate um
[Music]
one winning technique which actually
might be the most efficient way to win
like this small chess puzzle white to
move mate in five
white kc5 ne6 c7 e5
f6 black kc8 f7 wait wait wait wait
i need to i need to take it one one
position at a time
oh black actually okay
after the game i'll share what
uh line i was thinking of um
black allowed me to queen the c pawn
there is a line where i i would queen
with mate
okay so this is not stalemate because
this pawn has
three legal moves and that's mate
okay so that was that was actually a
pretty instructive game
so start the stream it was a ponziani
uh kind of tricky opening with queen a4
i won a pawn early black didn't get so
much compensation
um the mistakes for black were a bit
more subtle
like trading all the rooks was probably
one of the the biggest mistakes
um when you're blocking this position
you should really
try and keep at least one rook on the
board like takes
takes and then king f8 is a a better way
to resist
but it's still still probably very close
to winning for white
um oh so the line i wanted to
show because it's typical in king pawn
endings if king c8
i wouldn't be queening my my c pawn
but i would essentially put the king in
stalemate
oh yesterday's sleep schedule yeah it's
1am for me probably weird time for some
other
viewers too
so the king has no moves but the pawn
has a move
and after i take this pawn has a move
and then i can
could promote to a rook with mate for
the style points
so anyway that's kind of what i was
going for
one more thing if we go back to the
opening
the main line here and actually the best
move
like the main line theory here it's not
an easy move to play
if you're not familiar with it but it is
to play f6
maybe it is easy to play if you just
follow the rule always play f6
because it's the most effective way to
defend the e pawn
other moves like this or this
they defend e5 but they
lose d5 so
f6 and then i think this is a main line
bishop here attacking the knight and
then 97.
so it's a little bit awkward for black
but um
it is a reputable line if you know it
well
anyway so i'll probably put that on
youtube uh
i know youtube likes ponziani content
i think hopefully twitch does too
so another another ponziani video for
the youtube channel
twitch chat may be saying hi to youtube
youtube say hi to twitch chat
if you have prime you can subscribe for
free or you can gift
subs